so how it began was it said to me have  you noticed that every day is like every  other day somewhat said yes I've noticed  that and have you noticed that every  week is more or less like every other  week  yes well did you know that and this is a  typical mushroom construction this did  you know I'll bet you didn't know  and then the Hamming so did you know  I'll bet you didn't know that every day  has a relationship to four other days  and they are not the four days preceding  it they are scattered back through time  one of them maybe six months in the past  one of them maybe thousands of years in  the past  but each day is actually an interference  pattern caused by the resonant the  coming together of the resonances of  other times and so I had never occurred  to me I mean it's a weird idea it never  occurred to me that that was a  possibility and so then it said go get  your eaching and I went and got my  etching and it said we're going to look  at the first order of difference